welcome back everyone so first talking
by Anki and he tell us about analyzing
using minimization thanks shibungi this
okay
thanks to the organizers for inviting me
and thanks everyone for coming to talk
so yeah I'll be talking about analyzing
this alternating minimization algorithms
or we call them scaling algorithms using
algebraic methods this is based on joint
work with a bunch of people and many of
them are in the audience so yeah so
alternating minimization is a widely
used heuristic in machine learning
optimization and there very few
guarantees for when this algorithm
converges to the optimal solution and
there even fewer guarantees when it
converges to optimist optimal solution
in a polynomial number of iterations
okay and in this talk we'll see that in
the setting of group actions we can
prove efficient convergence guarantees
and for this we'll use tools from
invariant theory and representation
theory okay so yeah so we saw this
example so this is the first example we
saw this example in Navi stock is a non
negative matrix and you want to scale it
so what this means is that you want to
multiply each row by some number
multiply each column by some number and
you want that the resulting matrix is
doubly stochastic okay all the row and
column sums over so that's the problem
okay
matrix scaling and then we have this
synchron's algorithm that uses two
simple primitives we have row
normalization basically you multiply
each row of a by the inverse of the row
sum that's row normalization you just
multiply I a throw by RI inverse and
then there is a corresponding column
normalization very multiply a by the
inverse of the column sums okay ayat
column is multiplied by CI inverse K and
so you can notice that row normalization
makes the row sums 1 and column
normalization makes the columns and so
on but they don't go well with each
other
when you do core minimally
you might destroy the rules under and so
on okay but I think one suggested this
algorithm then you just alternately try
to fix those and that's in constant code
actually yeah this is not proposed by
sync on someone else before sync on but
sink on proved that this algorithm
converges to the to something to be
stochastic so yeah so there's this
theorem from sync on and knob in 1967
that says that this algorithm converges
whenever it should so it should only
converge when the permanent is getting
zero so we saw this is now is talk and
it converges benefit should okay so that
there was theorem of sync on and not so
sync on in 1964 proved the weaker
theorem that the algorithm converges
whenever all the entries are positive
but you don't need that so there was
rectified in this follow oh yeah but
they don't don't didn't provide any
efficient guarantees for convergence
yeah I mean that's probably because
maybe they didn't care what so but yeah
so the efficient guarantees were
provided in this paper of lineal
evidence convicted CERN in 2000 they
proved that in n log n over epsilon
iterations roughly so B is the bit
complexity so n times B plus log in over
epsilon iterations you get epsilon close
to W stochastic so if if you have a
doubly stochastic scaling you run this
algorithm in n times B plus log n over
epsilon iterations you will get epsilon
close to W statistic and what this means
there's a precise technical sense like
the l2 norm of the row and column sums
vector from the all one's vector is
steps you know okay
that's what any questions so far
yeah so they use permanent as a
potential function for the analysis of
their algorithm and the reason yeah the
question is why why do they use the
permanent and this so so there are two
reasons for this one is that the
algorithm evolves according to a series
of group actions right sort of you
applying the group action multiplying it
by a diamond matrix on the left and the
right so algorithm evolves according to
a series of group actions
okay that's one reason Bayou is
permanent and the other reason the
permanent is invariant with respect to
this group action so permanent is
invariant
respect to this group action so yeah I
write invariant in this quotes because
it's not exactly invariant it's
invariant up to a scalar so what do I
mean
so if you have permanent of v1 a d2 then
it's equal to the determinant of D 1
times permanent of a times determinant
of D 2 times permanent of a
where D 1 and D 2 are diagonal matrices
it's very easy to track the progress of
permanent as the algorithm involves
because it just changes by a scalar
every step we just have to chain the
scalar to keep track on the scale ok any
questions so far
yes yes all the products of the yeah
that does also but yeah
it doesn't matter you can use a
permanent here so permanent is invariant
okay yeah so that's why they use the
permanent as a potential function and in
this storm we will see that this
generalizes to other settings as well
and let's see other settings
okay so one other setting is this
setting of operator scaling which also
are we mentioned briefly d1 d2 - yeah -
determinant also it's correct it will
not be diagonal makes it so permanent
yeah so sort of view of this property
that permanent will start greater than
zero whenever you are scalable but
sometimes the determinant could be zero
for example the determinant of the all
ones matrix is zero that's something you
don't want you want that your sort of
convergence is characterized by nonzero
oh I see this using this why can't a
rate permanent I mean yeah just a short
notation you can write product of entry
it doesn't know you met right
determinant is opposed to permanent for
d1 this yeah the same
yeah but later determinant will be the
one - yeah it's determined
okay so yeah so one of the setting is
this operator scaling in this you have M
inputs so M matrices now they are not
non-negative they have complex entries
and you want them to satisfy these two
conditions okay so you want that sum
over I ai ai conjugate transposes
identity and also sum over I AI
conjugate ai ai conjugate transpose AI
is identity so you want these two
conditions and the operations that
you're allowed are the left reaction
okay so you can pick invertible matrices
B and C and post pre and post multiply
them simultaneously on the ears so those
are the operations so why I will accord
is this and so this turns out of the
gradient equals zero condition for this
norm square minimization for this
corresponding group action right so this
something are we briefly mentioned in
this talk so in general we are studying
this norm square minimization problem
and the gradient equals zero condition
turns out to be capturing these two
conditions okay and sort of yeah this
was also useful in this work on non
commutative - enlightening testing so I
won't go too much into it okay and if
you wanted to measure progress in some
sense yeah so it's invariant only up to
a scalar so that's why it's simple
interest like yeah it's very convenient
to track the progress because you just
have to see what the scalar is you just
have to prove the scale is at least 1 or
something keeps increasing years also in
some sense is right yeah I mean yeah
we'll see that this year this happens in
a number of examples I mean also yeah I
mean one thing also is that sort of the
convergence is characterized by a
permanent being greater than 0 so that
also gives you some hint that whenever
you will converge you have the potential
function is
yeah so you want this to conditions and
similarly similar to here you have these
two operations that you can do to
satisfy either of the two conditions so
one is one I'll call left normalization
where you can multiply all the AIS on
the left by this weird-lookin term so
it's just the inverse square root of
what you want to be identity okay so if
you do this you can do a calculation it
will ensure that the one is satisfied
okay and similarly so he should be right
similarly you can do this right
normalization where you can multiply
ears on the right by the inverse square
root of the other term that you want to
be identity and this will ensure the two
is satisfied and yeah so guru it's in
2004 he suggested this algorithm you can
just alternatively keep doing right left
and right normalization and yeah so when
he also proved that should it converges
whenever it should so that that is
whenever there is a scaling of this form
whenever there exists B and C such that
this condition is satisfied you can find
that them by sort of running this
iterative at what
so yeah so this sum sum over I e IA a
conjugate transpose if it's not
invertible then yeah then there's no way
of making this to identity by the
scaling like yeah then it's not scalable
it's the bad set oh yeah so guru it's
proved it converges whenever should any
proved efficient convergence bound in
special cases okay
and in this joint work with guru it's
Leonid row file and IV we proved that in
n log n over epsilon iterations you get
epsilon close to satisfying this
condition so it's I mean yeah you can
see that it's exactly the same bound
and yeah I mean epsilon close to
satisfying this condition there's
something like this you want that the
the some of this outer product
- identity Frobenius norm square are
small in both case so it's there okay
any questions there is one other setting
okay so let's look at the third setting
something that we call tensor scaling to
Venus no is the correct to measure it
with the same thing right but this is
the right one in calculations here yeah
so this is something called tensor
scaling okay so here the input is a 10 n
by N by n tensor okay and sort of you
want these three conditions to be
satisfied
so here so you have a tensor you can
slice it up in three directions you
slice it up and then you think of this
matrices that you get as vectors okay so
you form each of these you consider as a
n square vector and combining this n
square vectors you get n by n square
matrices okay so these are the three
flattening of the tensor okay so the
three n by n square matrix matrices you
get by flatting the tensor K ok so those
are these empty I and then you sort of
take the outer products of these so Rho
T I I'll say it's empty i mt i conjugate
transpose so this is the N by n matrix K
n by n positive definite matrix so far
and yeah I mean if you're interested so
if if you think of T as a quantum state
then these are the quantum marginals of
this quantum state but yeah doesn't
really matter for this purpose and what
you want in this setting is that all
these marginals are identity so this
video setting which sort of generalizes
this setting in some we want is that all
these marginal side identity questions
so I mean this turns out to be the
gradient equals zero condition for for
certain group action basically the group
action of GL n cross GL and chrigel and
all ten Suzuki and yeah is it useful we
don't know but yeah we can do this we
don't know if it's useful
yeah okay so the question is clear what
do you want why oh sorry sorry sorry
yeah I forgot to mention yeah so so
operations that you allowed is the group
action that I mentioned so Operations
Group action of GL n cross GL and cross
Yellin you can change bases from all the
three sides yeah so I won't go into
explicitly what you have to do but as in
the previous settings there's a way of
satisfying one of the conditions
basically you do the normalization in
this setting basically I mean you want
the slices to be orthogonal that's what
it means for this to be identity and you
can do this in this direction this
direction that any application for
Nelkin membership for that action yeah
yeah so because we're minimizing the
noms curve yeah so we don't really solve
the null current problem so yeah so let
me mention the result and then I'll say
why we don't solve the none control okay
so yeah so the algorithm that we sort of
suggested in this John work with Peter
profile Michael Walter nabhi and this
algorithm was also suggested before in
this paper of words there that you just
alternately normalize in all the three
directions so it's not a surprise by now
right that's the algorithm and I mean
yeah this paper didn't prove even
convergence for this algorithm and so
you're in this joint work we proved that
in n log n over epsilon iterations you
get epsilon close to satisfying the
conditions so again the boundary is
exactly the same yeah so you're
regarding the null cone problem it turns
out that to solve the null cool problem
you want the algorithm to have a
logarithmic dependence on one over
epsilon that's so if if if you had a
bound like and maybe poly and
and log 1 over epsilon instead of 1 over
Epsilon so if you had such an algorithm
that would solve an outcome oh yes yeah
in the Epsilon Pi maybe exponentially
faster yes ok so any questions
algorithms perform just yeah I think
they should be tied even the matrix
scaling case ok so yeah so let me see
yeah so let me say something about the
analysis of this algorithm so it turns
out a unified way of an analyzing this
algorithms using invariant theory salon
there so that's a good question
yeah somehow here you only need the one
over epsilon yeah I mean we can talk
offline like so I mean it's like in for
linear programming right some linear
programs you can solve by this 1 over
epsilon kind of value algorithms like
here like matrix scaling or like by bird
matching you don't need all this fancy
machinery of linear programming but for
generally any program you need this law
in our exponent so it's the same thing
that's going on in just about the
distance of your office closer from the
point 0 in the case it does not contain
in some case it is just probably not
very small and that's enough in some
cases it's exponentially small and you
need a much better I mean yeah it's not
exactly the distance that is near so and
the reason really is that there is a
whole condition for that case and there
is no pole condition like that for this
case yeah there's some community really
like a linear algebraic condition in
this case but not in this case
yeah so we'll see yeah so they'll be
ingredients so yeah so now I have to
write something
okay so the framework for analyzing this
algorithm is the following so the word
will be the potential functions for
analyzing and as we saw in the matrix K
with this case it was the permanent
right and in general the potential
functions will look like this so you
have your input V and the potential
function will be something like some
invariant evaluated V to power 1 ody so
P is an invariant to scalar for the
corresponding detection
and it's it's homogeneous of degree D so
using V like V in this case denotes a in
the matrix scaling case tuple of
matrices in the operator scaling case
and tensor in the tensor skinny case
okay so potential functions will be you
choose and invariant or homogeneous of
degree D for the corresponding group
action and just take one over to get
power the polynomial P is a polynomial
invariant form this way yeah
and given this potential function there
are three natural steps that you to
follow you have two lower bound you want
to prove that E is at least L initially
and then there's a progress per step
it's usually involves saying that you
make progress as far as long as you're
far from satisfying the conditions so
you make progress whenever you can make
progress
so normalization step increases this fee
by a factor of e to the epsilon if you
are Absalon far from satisfying the
conditions so it's some lower bound you
will prove on your initial potential
function it's something like yeah one
would Pauline aim for no merely none in
we are moving expeditiously minus n or
something so now from far from
satisfying the conditions so whenever
you are Absalon from satisfying the
conditions you normalization really
please the potential function by a e to
the absolute factor and the upper bound
is that you want that fee is upper
bounded by some there's an upper bound
you and this is always satisfied so
initially you have the lower one fee is
load 1 to the N and normalization
increases by a factor of e to the
epsilon if your epsilon Phi and fee is
always up reported by you period right
so then in log of u by L over epsilon
iterations
you have to get epsilon close satisfying
the [ __ ] conditions right so that's the
flavor of the analysis that goes into
these things okay can you say what
senses be invariant I mean the rounds
are question again oh yeah so when you
say on the one hand it's in three areas
but at the same time is growing okay so
yeah send up to the scaler so let me
write it for the yeah so maybe let me
write it so let's say no pretty scaling
case you have this you have M inputs and
you act by B and C on both sides and
then this will be equal to determinant
of B times the determinant of C to the
power B over n so d is a degree of p
times p-1
you so in it's invariant up to the
determinants acting weird
whether you're acting with let's say the
general in a group of especially not to
or with diagonal matrices are battalion
versus diagonal matrices of determinant
one this this is the only difference so
it is really an invariant if you enforce
it the coming up one condition
and if you don't picture a lot let's
start with them allowed to do you get
exactly good focus but do they have to
choose that piece judiciously yes yeah
yeah we have to be the choose the piece
judicially so yeah so in these three
steps the second step is very automatic
like it just used this follow the recipe
of LSW and follows and it involves some
robust version of am human quality okay
so it yeah it really boils down to
proving that these determinants are at
least one or at least e to the epsilon
and this just follows syntactically i
mean this as follows from these epsilon
four conditions using some robust
version of EMG okay so this is really
automatic and exactly the same in all
the all these papers
so this notion of using this sort of
invariant under the sense it's just so
that you can sort of measure progress
just by how far you were from your
target and not about what point you are
I mean you don't want this to really
depend on even through here yeah how far
you were from your it turns out that
yeah that's what these two okay yeah so
yeah so so this step is really automatic
and not so hard and just we do that list
everything and lower bound and upper
bound you need to you pick this
invariance judiciously as skatin said
and sort of here we need some help from
invariant theory so basically what we
need and what you need are that there
exists invariants with not too large
coefficients not too large interior
coefficients
and degree also yeah so turns out in
these cases degree doesn't matter like
the degree term just cancels out
miraculously but in general you would
need exponential degree bounds also but
in these cases you do don't need okay so
you need coefficient bounds for
invariants so let me just state a formal
thing for the tensors K so for tensors
this is a theorem which we proved in but
yeah I mean this is basically relying
heavily on the past invariant theory
theorems so there exists a basis of
degree D invariants in invariants in
this relative sense such that so I mean
so degree D invariants form a vector
space and there exists a basis of this
vector space such that all basis
polynomials have integer coefficients
and more importantly the coefficients
are not too large so I will write it in
terms of this condition that we actually
need in the analysis so when you
evaluate P on any vector V this is at
most and like put the 1 over D a power
this is at most n cube times their 2
norm of the vector B for all polynomials
in the basis the coefficients are not
too large this is what you need from the
invariant
so Omega process yeah so yes I'll say
that this exactly does not come from the
maker process so yeah so so yeah is this
theorem non-trivial or not and it also
this term is exactly highly non-trivial
so there are some trivial bounds you can
get here okay you can reduce finding
invariants to solving systems of linear
equations and the bounds you will get
will be typically expert doubly
exponential indeed okay so you will get
very bad bounds if you do this naively
but yeah I just turns out miraculously
that people have highly non explicit
constructions or mean variance in this
case but since we only need some big
guarantees on this problem is you can
just read off these theorem from those
constructions okay and in general there
also they are also these processes to
generate the invariants and one is
Skelly's omega processors kept and said
and those will also give some bounds
here they will they will be worse but
they will still guarantee polynomial
number of iterations yes so in the in
the operator scaling K s matrix killing
case you can but not here I mean you can
write them down but yeah it's a messy
expression all you can reduce the
coefficient bonds that what we wanted
but they're the tensor case we don't
know they may involve some commutation
so we know the structure
we know this job yeah so in in some
settings like in matrix scaling there
several algorithms getting long when our
epsilon in the operator scaling case
also we have some algorithms getting log
in our epsilon but no in the tensor case
we don't have them get is there hope
here to do exist where you you also can
different messages yeah you can find
capacity yeah and we will like it to
prove without the capacity bounds on the
capacity bizarro textual rewired still
no be used in very interior Valley we
use the characterization of the
invariants early there is a bond which
uses only Huber to existence you only
but you also needed the structure of the
invariants right we use the structure of
the invariants to position yeah so you
know so and you prove pretty much using
so and here here you can get to the
bottom the capacities yeah yeah so
that's done go to the same analysis and
use capacity also but yeah you need
coefficient boundary mate
[Music]